what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to geek culture explained
where i will make you an expert on all
things related to geek culture in 10
minutes or less and today
i want to try something different so if
you're familiar with my beyond omega
level series over on comics explain this
video is basically going to be the same
thing and because the mortal kombat
movie is coming out this week i want to
explain the strongest character in the
mortal kombat franchise
fire god luke king now there are several
insanely powerful characters in the
mortal kombat universe of course you
have shao khan who for those of you guys
who grew up playing the mortal kombat
games was thought to be the most
powerful character ever
and then later on the series would
introduce other powerful characters like
shao khan's predecessor onaga the dragon
king and we would also see the concept
of elder gods and titans introduced but
even so the fire god lu kang
stands above them all as the most
powerful but in order to understand the
concept of fire god luke king we first
need to go over who luke kang is now if
you're not at all familiar with mortal
kombat you undoubtedly have some
familiarity with liu kang he is one of
the original seven playable characters
in the first mortal kombat game he was
the main character
of the mortal kombat movie so he's
pretty recognizable to fans but while
the original mortal kombat was basically
just a fighting game they got popular
because it was ultra violent and had
lots of blood
wins fatality over the years a fair
amount of lore has been added to round
out the characters and just to be clear
all the stuff that we're talking about
today takes place in the current mortal
kombat timeline that was rebooted with
the release of 2011's mortal kombat so
luke kang was an orphan and was taken in
by the shaolin monks and began training
in martial arts at an early age
the shaolin quickly realized that liu
kang had the potential to be formidable
in the mortal kombat tournament a fact
that was also realized by the thunder
god
raiden and so seeing lou kang as the
best hope for earth realm
raiden takes him to train with beau
raicho a martial arts master who likes
to partake of alcoholic beverages and
employs a fighting style known as the
drunken
fist and so with all this training liu
kang earns the right to be one of the
warriors representing earth realm in the
mortal kombat tournament and raiden who
had become a mentor of luke hanks is
contacted by his future self and his
future self basically tells him
he must win now written believes that
the he that his future self is referring
to is luke hank because at that point
he's the only earthrealm warrior left in
the mortal kombat tournament so it just
made good sense now liu kang does win
the tournament after defeating goro and
shang tsung but when raiden's amulet
begins to crack
even more he starts to think that maybe
he'd misinterpreted the message he'd
received from his future self and that
maybe
luke hang was a loser and not a winner
now in the next mortal kombat tournament
raiden believes that kung lao a former
shaolin monk that's thought to be fairly
equal to liu kang in terms of ability
is the one that must win kung lao is
able to defeat both shang tsung and the
demonic sorcerer quan qi in a two-on-one
battle but just as it appears that kung
lao is on the brink of victory here
comes xiao khan who snaps his neck
earth
now because kung lao was basically liu
kang's bestie luke heng
isn't really happy about this he gets
mad as hell and he challenges shao khan
for killing his friend because you know
that's what you do when somebody kills
your friend now not only does he defeat
shao khan but it seems as if he kills
him although later it would be revealed
this was not the case and he actually
just mounts an invasion of earth realm
but the invasion is against the rules of
the mortal kombat tournament because
one realms only really permitted to
invade another if they best them in
mortal combat
10 consecutive times and at this point
luke hang had scored two consecutive
victories for
earth realm and so reign and liu kang go
to the elder gods who set up the rules
of the tournament in the first place to
try to convince them to intervene and
stop shao khan's invasion but despite
the invasion being a blatant violation
of the rules the elder gods are like no
we don't really care just uh
figure it out right we're watching
snowfall but following this raiden makes
a suggestion to ask quan chi for help
and luke kang just decides that raiden's
lost his mind and so raiden then reveals
that he now believes that the he
and he must win does not refer to liu
king or kung lao but to shao
and so liu kang challenges raiden but
raiden defeats him and then liu kang
hits raiden with his signature fiery
punch but when met with raiden's bolts
of electricity this backfires to
severely burn liu kang and then he
eventually dies from his injuries after
telling raiden
[Music]
you have killed us
now liu kang has then taken another
realm where he exists as an undead
revenant in service of quan chief and
after the elder god shinnok is freed liu
kang
pledges his allegiance to him and vows
to help him overthrow the other elder
gods because you know he's still pissed
off at raiden for killing him now liu
kang battles his former allies notably
raiden who once again
defeats him now once shinnok is defeated
luke king becomes one of the rulers of
the nether realm along with his
girlfriend katana and so liu kang
continues to be influenced by shinnok
and plans his own invasion of earth
realm the invasion is unsuccessful but
does lead to the return of
chronica a member of a race known as the
titans and the mother of shinnok you'd
think they'd get done
doing like family members of of shinnok
people like that and just be like here's
chronica
she taught him math in like the third
grade but chronica possesses the ability
to manipulate time and one result of
this is that the past version of liu
kang is brought to the present so now we
have a good luke hang and an evil loo
kang running around
the two versions of liu kang fight with
the younger version emerging victorious
the evil lou kang once again faces off
with raiden but only after raiden tries
to reason with him explaining that
chronica manipulated the timeline to
ensure that luke hang and raiden would
battle in every timeline and liu kang
was destined to die
every single time and so raiden defeats
lukang but instead of killing him he
merges himself with the revenant version
of liu kang as well as the physical body
of the deceased
liu kang creating fire god luke hank now
with his consciousness restored and in
possession of new godly powers
fire god luke kang is able to defeat an
entire army of chronica soldiers and
then battles chronicle herself who uses
her powers to take the battle
to the beginning of time but she's
eventually defeated by liu kang who uses
his fire abilities to turn her into
glass before destroying her which was
really really amazing but after this
luke hang and raiden are separated with
luke kang remaining a god while raiden
becomes mortal and so liu kang is given
the title of protector of earth realm
and keeper of time he then uses
chronica's hourglass to rewrite the
timeline itself which results in a
showdown between fire god luke hank and
shang tsung who's obtained kronika's
crown hoping to take on her role for
himself now how the battle plays out
depends on whether the player of the
game chooses to fight as shang tsung
or fire god liu kang and so i don't
really think we can really learn much
about the relative strength of either
based on this battle but the fact that
fire god luke hang was able to defeat
cronica who would probably be the
character that we're talking about here
if it weren't for the existence of fire
god liu kang is a testament to how
strong he really is
chronica was a threat that seemed
unbeatable until she wasn't as she was
able to affect the time stream itself
the fire god liu kang gets the job done
and literally saves the world and all of
creation from inevitable destruction but
because we see fire god liu kang for
such a short period of time we don't
really have any other feats to go on to
gauge his power level but liu kang was
honestly
extremely powerful already having
defeated some of the fiercest warriors
in mortal kombat including goro shang
tsung and xiao khan so when you take
probably the best fighter in the
entirety of the universe who already had
the ability to control fire in his
normal form and who given the powers of
the thunder god raiden which allows him
to become a firebender from the fire
nation this is pretty much
a no-brainer but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you guys later
peace